attention cloud 9 shoppers the store has
been closed for 20 minutes many of us
would like to leave so if you're still
in the store you're being a dick
don't be a dick it's tough because I
have to live with this trashcan you know
right no I get it it's a very big
decision so you know maybe you could go
home tonight sleep on it and decide
tomorrow
no decide tomorrow is what I said
yesterday I don't get home is study for
my midterm I'm totally screwed oh hey
you look so cute thank you it's my
senior dance recital tonight what why
don't you tell us why I can't perform
because of you know this but I'm gonna
go and cheer on the other girls
yeah if this bozo ever leaves the store
hey Myrtle go bust out your hysterectomy
story that's alright I got it
it was 1953 and medical science was all
the rage the thing is you just sent us
two shipment of signs now and I'd hate
to keep people late on a Friday evening
to hang them all up so if anyone gets
this message could you call me back
please
it's Glenn turn bizarro oh oh sorry
sorry
oh hey I'm in the way duty calls hey is
that I heart - that is the best diet
how many nights oh great job a tail
great job to do more work I'm so sorry I
just found out about it
I feel terrible
you